first things first we're gonna make a
really nice caramel add 150 grams of
caster sugar to a pan followed by a
couple of star anise next lightly
crushed four cardamom pods this has a
lovely warm Spicy Sweet flavor then wait
for the sugar to melt and form a caramel
smell of that caramel is amazing now
cranberries in
cranberries are very tart and acidic but
balanced with the sweetness of the
caramel and apples they give the sauce a
lovely dry sharp note next core peel and
thinly slice two apples
Now The Cranberries are starting to
break down Apple in
the smell is fantastic it's not a sort
of sweet sour spicy delays the pan with
a touch of Port deglazing dissolves all
the lovely sticky caramelized bits of
food that are stuck to the pan and
incorporates them into the sauce
next add the zest of an orange and for
another layer of fragrant sweetness
squeezing the juice then cook on a low
heat for five to ten minutes to thicken
if you really want to get ahead this
sauce can be made three or four days in
advance